et on retrouve en duplex de paris maître
nathalie tommasini avocate donc de cette
femme valérie la décision est tombée
tombée hier c'est une première victoire
pour vous alors que le parquet avait
fait appel de cette remise en liberté
oui c'est une première victoire
en tous les cas nous sommes à la fois
très ému par cette décision est
satisfaite car les magistrats semblent
avoir été à l'ecoute et sensibles
notamment aux conclusions des experts
judiciaires que nous avons développées à
l'audience les experts judiciaires dont
nous avons cruellement manqué dans le
cas de la fin de chaque ligne sauvage
experts judiciaires qui ont retenu la
notion d'emprise dont était victime
valérie mac os durant toute sa vie
la notion de syndrome de femme battue et
la notion de postes traumatismes
psychologiques sévères
justement m qui est votre cliente je
veux dire par là
quel est son profil c'est une chaîne
farm donc là comparativement avec
jacqueline sauvage ce n'est pas du tout
la même personnalité nous avons une
femme qui a aujourd'hui 37 ans qui a été
abusée sexuellement par entre guillemets
la victime donc son mari daniel paulette
qui a été abusée sexuellement à l'âge de
12 ans et qui par la suite va épouser
cet homme parce qu'elle tombera enceinte
de saison 2 de ces de ces nouvelles
manoeuvres et agression sexuelle il
l'épousera elle aura quatre enfants avec
ce dernier et
elle vivra une vie de souffrance à la
fois de violences physiques
psychologiques elle sera également
prostituée par ces derniers est-ce
qu'elle avait alerté de cette situation
avant d'en venir à l'irréparable
elle a tenté de le faire notamment ses
enfants aussi ont tenté de le faire
rien n'a été engagée car la réception
qu'ils ont eue auprès des commissariats
auprès des officiers de police
judiciaire a été a été vaine
ces derniers n'ont pas reçu l'accueil
qu'ils auraient souhaité ont l'art
simplement dit que il y aurait peut-être
un éloignement de la part du mari
violent et ils ont estimé qu'un
éloignement leur père leur mari pour
valérie les retrouverez toujours et
qu'ils seraient alors là en danger de
mort permanent et véritable maître vous
avez été l'avocat de jacqueline sauvage
la sphère est quand même très
différentes ici on parle d'assassinât il
faut le rappeler sont les termes de la
justice aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on est dans une nouvelle
affaire de ce type parce qu'on est aussi
dans le procès des violences conjugales
bien évidemment il est évident que les
débats devant la cour d'assises
porteront sur les notions que nous avons
toujours retenu est soulevée à savoir la
notion d'entreprise et la notion de
syndrome de femme battue donc sans
préjuger de nos arguments de défense
on peut dire que il y a tout de même des
similitudes avec la sphère de shakin
sauvage et c'est une nouvelle fois une
femme qui vivait dans un foyer conjugal
ou demeurant qui n'était pas du tout
content et c'est en tout cas dans leurs
relations par les personnes extérieures
qui les côtoyaient on ne pouvait pas
imaginer qu'elle vivait un tel enfer
et pourtant c'était le cas merci mais le
sujet bien sûr je vous en prie merci
d'avoir été notre invité en direct
depuis paris